我有一个特别棒的技能
可以说是我的中技技能
终于到这个话题了
怎么自学
短视频是可以学的
多不小老师
哎呀是可以
学的
赚钱的方法也是可以学的
那我的学一方法的话呢就是两位
你累就这约度
比如说书籍啊比如说包括呀
文章啊
另外一类的话呢就是房谈
就我很喜欢房谈这个方式
尤其我做的自媒体
然后也唱到百万大位之后的话呢
我在房谈的时候就可以就会方便很多
但是我房谈和别人房谈不太一样
很多人房谈是为了流量
我对流量关注度不是那么高
我更多的是希望
借助这个房谈从对方身上学到一些东西
所以大家如果有些人可以看的话
只要是我房谈过的人这个身上有些特别强的拥严
我通常都会把它
吸打过来成为我身体的一部分就是过去不有个习近大把嘛这个东西是真的
比如说前两天我
去房谈服务的
小报同的然后木部的联合创生上呢
就这个路量就不太好
这种人也可能都不太好
但是我其实特别喜欢这个房谈
就很多人让我都会看了很多别
然后呢我觉得
来到这个短视频平台之后的话我也想到了福利所以有些时候
哪怕没有流量我也希望把一些好的东西分享给大家
所以呢我把一些
我觉得有些东西吧我摘去一下
给大家一个导演
真正有用的知识是什么
各位不是说我知道就是有些时候你访谈的时候不是说从对方身上知道一个你不知道的东西
这个时代就是我们想我们那个信息是平船的
所以真正重要的不是说你从人身上得到一个你不知道的东西而是你从身上得到一些其实你本来就知道
但是你没有重视的知识
或者从另外一个角度来看这个问题
后来一个来这个东西可能更重要要把它放到前面去
比如说我后面给大家解决一下多少
第一个部分提到了就是商量说他当时去
武器的一个大学学习结果呢
没有客家
没有客场也没有说的老师都不知道老师都是现学前面
然后我在中装的时候去学习等级我们老师也是一样也是现实面
哇这个太棒了
各位真正是太棒了
就是
你知道吗你去一个地方干老师学习会发现老师也不会
这个很棒这个是非常非常棒的一件事情
平你去一个学校
老师什么都知道
我就要帮很多
这是一个非常棒的奇迹后面
为什么帮大家可以
看后半那个视频
还有部分的话就是提到了注意力
我说现在很久是不学习的然后上南还有不同的观点但是说其实是注意力确实
然后我们来到注意的话题
注意力这个话题是非常棒的两个话题
第一个问题就是
能够细别人的注意力是一种权力
我希望各位好好的也得以后
就是能够细别人的注意力是用权力过在视频的有提到
另外一个就是你要去
你要去
保住自己的注意力把这个注意力放在一个比较重要的地方
还有一块是到底该怎么学习
这个学习他替到一个干点就是
很多时候我们学习
是因为我们没有提出一个好的问题
当你提出一个好的问题的时候其实你的学习就非常容易了
好 我不多说了就是
我爸爸这段视频介绍来给大家看
我希望大家认真地去看
里边的这个那种不是我知道就可以的
知道屁股不定
关键是你知道了以后你把它用在你的
生活中
我们那个系特别搞笑我们来扣不着都没
那些新组件呢
你没三斤骂死何马雅是不是那时候
但是那只是两个软件
但你这个四年的课什么的什么设计
有没有一些课本
改革那些课我们都是一边走一边摩索的
我们经常被出现了特别搞笑的事情就老实放了个教授说
老实在昨天晚上我下载客玩了
对很多时候他的教授都是晚上大人的老实在搬
老实在搬那些继续听
所以那你像在你创业吗
他这一路都是在自己导臥自己去
他没有什么很多很多成体系的东西
这其实对我来说是好事
对了我们好事因为我们整好感上了一个时代浪潮的开始
对
那也就是说我们是进入这个领域里边我们会有信息差核实之事
但今天我觉得特别好就是因为你获取信息的成本基本上没有了
以前多了一点的习个资金是跑到树上去买树
对吧是的
而且你还买不到树
但现在问题是什么的现在是大部分是不写习的
我觉得
也不能叫不写习我的是我们的注意力被洗走的
我觉得所以你要想学习的第一个问题我觉得是
你自己有没有什么问题问自己
对很多人会说我想学习但是我先刷一下那个视频吧
对吧我想学习但是我先看一个句吧
那其实他是没有一个很破确的问题在问自己说这问就要解决
当你想要解决一个问题的时候你就自然去学习
这媒体的一个东西特别重要
我是越来越认识到媒体重要的一些事情
我今天看很多朋友说
如果我穿越回古代
我第一个要干的行李就是树
我会逐漸一个树树团队
我这个就是个权利的象征
OK
是吧
所以你就会发现
吸引别人的注意力
这件事情本身就是一种权利
然后我就特别能够理解就是那个Tick Talk的那个什么
我特别能够理解
因为那个
漂亮
他其实就本身就是利用媒体的方式
是来
对吧
所以
我就把他理解为就是当你能够学习当你能够
分享知识的时候怕本身就是一种很软心的权利
是的
但反过来就是如果你要想学习
你一件事就是你要保护好你的注意力是的
对吧
保护注意力你也不说我在这傻的带着我就是保护注意力对吧
那你肯定说我要么是消费我们是创造
我创造什么呢
我肯定是有了一个问题
我想做一个好吃的饭
对吧
我想写一个影片
然后呢我可能想解到题
是的
那你是你又没有去
注意你想解决什么问题
那这个是最重要的一个第一件事我觉得
学习的第一件事就是你有
翻译你有一个问题
而不是别人告诉说你要学这个东西
今天我觉得很多人学习是
你该去学习呀
你该去你该去你该去你该去你该去
哪儿那么多该呀你自己
真的有那样的一个问题吗
我特别同意这点
就是我说这话可能会得到这很多
建书的博主啊
因为
我经常会有一个朋友就是护推荐到得经啊
推荐这个
丛电是吧
丛通电啊
然后推荐这个中国方的家书啊
对啦就是几帝给我推荐
我呀明
我对玩家明都会给我推荐这些东西
然后我就问他
我为什么要看结束
我不明白我为什么要看结束
对他给我几帝推荐说我为什么要看结束
因为我过承认这些书是好书
对
但是对我来说有什么用
对吧
所以当你给我推荐的一本好书而且我也认为这个好书啊你承误的说服了我
然后我去看这个书的时候
他成功了
哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
他成功了对吧
我的时间我的经历我最宝贵的
财富对注意力注意力
被你们拿走了是的
对吧
所以我觉得你刚才说的是对的就是你要做什么事
不应该是有别人告诉你
或者是别人告诉你的仅认是参考你最后一定决定
我要做什么事对
但这一切权你的第一个发问就是哎那我想干什么
不是我有什么困惑我们是吧是搞清楚
所以我觉得很多人
做比借好学习或者说跟别人拿贴好
你看刚才我就注意乎自高几个特点我从你上偷到了你得几个好问题